[Music]
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
those days making cartoons is hard work
but it seems like the animators of the
loud house can't catch a break the last
mistake really makes us wonder just how
much we don't know about Lincoln if
you're a loud house superfan make sure
you give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to never miss another video
now let's check out ten mistakes in the
loud house you might have missed lisa's
clothing let's start with the very first
episode of the series called left in the
dark the plot of this episode is very
simple but it allows us to get to know
every single sibling of the loud family
Lincoln wants to watch the finale of his
favorite series when suddenly the power
goes out if you've watched our other
loud house videos you'll know that this
is also the episode where the show makes
one of its tributes the Spongebob
Squarepants as this was the very first
episode it's probably the one with the
most animation mistakes but there's one
that stands out the most have you ever
noticed Lisa's sweater this is the only
episode that features a dark green
sweater on Lisa in all others you'll see
you're wearing a chartreuse color which
is a mix of yellow and green apart from
her sweater Lisa's chip tooth also makes
an appearance here but it disappears in
other episodes
apart from mistakes the first episode
also introduces us to many running gags
this show has and if you're a super fan
we recommend going back and re watching
them all you'd be surprised how much all
the characters have changed since the
first time they've appeared on TV of
course apart from our sweater the four
year old Lisa still has the same
personality throughout the show and it's
precisely why we love her whose bike is
it anyway if you have a lot of siblings
you've probably owned quite a few
hand-me-downs from clothes and bikes to
other objects that were passed on for
sentimental value as well as other
reasons most children have a love/hate
relationship with hand-me-downs it's
safe to say that when your family has
eleven children hand-me-downs are very
common but they're not always
appreciated in an episode called
hand-me-down ER
Lincoln gets a pink bike from his
seventeen year old sister
Loree needless to say he's not very
excited about it
so he ends up borrowing a BMX from his
sporty sister Lin without letting her
know his bike was a hand-me-down from
Lin to Lana but you can still see him
use the same bike in a couple of later
episodes we have no idea what happened
and why it happened but it's safe to say
the animation team has their hands full
with this many characters did Lincoln
use his old bike because he didn't like
lorries and took it back from his
younger sisters don't worry if you're
confused because we are - we can't blame
Lincoln though he really does not look
excited about that pink bike on the
other hand Clyde looks totally smitten
he probably knows the bike was used by
Lori his longtime crush ah the joys of
childhood Lincoln and Lola another
interesting mistake is the relationship
between Lincoln and Lola the two are
very different characters but they tend
to be allies most of the time the
six-year-old Lola is a pageant queen
that's always sporting a tiara and a
sassy attitude on the other hand the
11-year old Lincoln is much more chill
and calm but surprisingly the two seemed
to get along for most of the time
Lincoln's nickname for Lola is sunshine
while Lola called Lincoln philistine at
some point their relationship as brother
and sister is cute and fun to watch in
an episode called hope friction Lincoln
makes a comic book of superheroes that
are based on his sisters he mentions
that every single one of his sisters has
his back but Lola if you're a loud house
superfan you know that Lola had
Lincoln's back and helped him out plenty
of times
was this a storyline mistake or
something the team behind the loud house
just simply missed even though she can
be feisty we promised Lola's not as
annoying to Lincoln as she might seem to
her other sisters the two seem to get
along for the most part so we're not
sure why Lincoln would think Lola would
not have his back then again the pageant
queen might just be too busy focusing on
other beauty things who's Ronnie
and speaking of storylines sometimes the
story of the loud house takes a
completely unexpected turn you might
notice some characters appearing in
places you'd never expect them to in an
episode called shell-shocked we get to
see Lincoln interact with Ronnie and
who's Lori's boyfriend's little sister
she also has a huge crush on Lincoln in
previous episodes Rani endlessly bullied
Lincoln to the point where Lincoln
openly admitted he doesn't want to be
Ronnie's boyfriend the things take an
interesting turn and over time his
feelings change the two are seen
together in class but here's the thing
they were never in the same class in any
of the previous episodes fans aren't
sure if this is something that was done
on purpose or did the team just miss out
on this tiny detail although since
Ronnie Ann's obsession with Lincoln is
pretty strong we can imagine she somehow
found a way to transfer herself into
Lincoln's class it wouldn't be the first
time a cartoon character did sneaky
things like that
just remember Helga from hey Arnold we
bet Ronnie and learned a few tricks from
Helga and used her on Lincoln we'll have
to see until further episodes to
determine whether or not this was a
storyline mistake it would definitely be
weird if Ronnie would suddenly be back
in her old classroom Lynne and Lincoln
speaking of interest in relationships
Lynne and Lincoln aren't known not to
get along although they're very similar
in age the 13 year old Lynne is far too
competitive and usually makes a
competition out of everything if you
have siblings you know what that's like
not a day goes by without someone being
declared a winner in something
completely unrelated well the
relationship between Lynne and Lincoln
is kind of similar these two can often
be seen fighting and it's no secret that
Lynne sometimes even bullies Lincoln but
here's the thing the two have been
roommates in an episode called room with
a feud where they prove they don't
really make good roommates at all and
there are several other episodes out
there where they seem to get along just
fine
well it's true the interactions between
siblings are completely unpredictable we
still don't know whether this was a
mistake in the storyline or just
something that was done on purpose Lynne
also believes Lincoln is bad luck
whenever he comes to her games and
sports events because she tends to lose
whenever he's there you have to admit it
their sibling rivalry is sometimes
absolutely hilarious Lynne is one of the
most tomboyish siblings out of the loud
family she'd probably make a competition
out of who's the most tomboyish with her
six-year-old sister
Lana children's allergies each of the
lighthouse characters has
unique personality usually described
down to a tee we get to learn everything
about them what they like what they
dislike and other secrets they don't
even tell their own family but here's an
interesting character trait that seems
to change in the loud house allergies
are very common and it's safe to say
that out of eleven siblings there would
probably be at least one that's allergic
to something well that doesn't seem to
be the case with a loud house in an
episode called One Flew Over the loud
house Lincoln mentioned that nobody has
any allergies in the family however in
fool's paradise we discover that Lana is
actually allergic to rhubarb after her
face swells up when she eats rhubarb pie
she then claims that she's allergic to
rhubarb and doesn't eat it anymore
but here's an issue we managed to find a
rhubarb allergy doesn't actually seem to
exist it's extremely hard to determine
whether or not someone is allergic to
rhubarb as the vegetable isn't commonly
eaten rhubarb allergies aren't exactly
common and they usually come from a
different food source so with Lana
really be able to know she's allergic to
rhubarb in the first place
although when answering the question
whether the family has any allergies
we're pretty sure someone like LuAnn
would say they're only allergic to each
other
Lenny doing her nails here's an
interesting one the 16 year old Lenny is
very much a girly girl who is quite the
fashionista she's always sporting her
awesome white sunglasses and a cute
outfit the only sibling who's probably
just as interested in doing girly things
is the six year old Lola in an episode
called a tale of two tables we see Lenny
and Lauri hanging out on the sofa
they're not in a particularly good mood
in Lenny's doing her nails while Lori's
on her phone as always but here's the
thing the characters in the loud house
much like most of the cartoon characters
don't even have visible nails so what
exactly is Lenny doing she's also seen
painting her nails in the same scene
which we don't even see from Lola was
this just an interesting insight into
what the animation team is capable of or
a mistake it's definitely interesting
seeing Lenny pamper her up and revealing
parts of her body like her fingernails
that we never even knew she had in the
first place speaking of the two
fashionistas which one do you think is a
bigger pageant queen the two are one of
the few sisters that are seen wearing
earrings we also learned that Lenny
doesn't wear socks and she really does
not
how to cook Laurie's white lies let's
explore some more mistakes in the loud
house that you might have missed these
are impressive and we can imagine that
they were only picked up by superfans
let's spend a few moments talking about
the seventeen-year-old Laurie Laurie's
the oldest in the family and she's
always seen as the most dominating of
the bunch
she has no issues and letting her
siblings know that she's the oldest and
that they should do what she tells them
to do because of it but Laurie's
storyline and personality have gone
through a few changes over the seasons
we call them Laurie's white lies they're
not that serious but they're pretty
interesting in an episode called the
green house Laurie has no idea what the
Mona Lisa is in one of the previous
episodes Laurie did actually understand
the reference to Mona Lisa in an episode
called comes sail away Laurie is seen
wearing earrings in a photo from a
couple of years ago she mentions she
received them from Bobbie her boyfriend
but we found out from another episode
that Laurie and Bobbie were only dating
for a few months were they really
Bobby's earrings was this a white lie
that hinted she got them from another
boy in her life or was it simply a
mistake in the storyline Lincoln's
friends it seems like Lincoln is the
character that's involved in most of the
mistakes we've mentioned today did you
know that his hair is white because the
original characters of the loud house
were suppose to be rabbit it's also the
reason behind Lincoln's buckteeth Ronnie
Ann's relationship with Lincoln deserves
to have a separate entry but let's spend
a moment talking about Lincoln's friends
the series introduces us to Clyde Liam
Zack and rusty who are Lincoln's
classmates we absolutely love their
individual look and the fact that both
Clyde and rusty have a crush on one of
Lincoln's sisters but here's the thing
that's bothering us with Lincoln's
friends
Lincoln is supposed to know his
classmates for five years but in
hand-me-down urk Lincoln meets rusty for
the first time in fact rusty was one of
those kid bikers that laughed at
Lincoln's pink bike that's also a
mystery on its own so what really is the
story behind Lincoln's friends how long
did he know them for he seems to get
along with rusty now but we doubt he
knew him as long as he knew his other
classmates again this could be something
the creators completely missed or it was
done on purpose so we could
talk about the show in this video
speaking of Lincoln's friends our
favorite is definitely the adorable
Clyde how about you Lincoln and Lily and
last but not least let's talk about the
relationship between Lincoln and Lily we
made quite a few out house videos so far
but we barely talked about the 15-month
Lily considering she hasn't yet
developed a personality like her other
siblings each sibling has their own
relationship with Lily but Lincoln and
Lily seem exceptionally close and we
often see him take care of her Lily is a
happy baby that usually doesn't cause
much trouble and the two seem to really
get along but we have no idea whether
Lincoln is actually able to take care of
Lily or not in an episode where Lincoln
and Clyde babysit Lily it looks like
they are really struggling with taking
care of her but yet in a couple of
previous episodes Lincoln has no
problems with being there for Lily
babysitting her and making sure she's a
happy baby it looks like we really don't
know the real Lincoln and we're blaming
it all on the team behind the loud house
what do you think we bet Lincoln is
totally capable of taking care of his
little sister as it was proven in so
many other episodes we can't wait to see
what kind of person Lily will turn out
to be as she gets older want more of the
loud house on this channel make sure you
like this video and subscribe don't
forget to check out ten loud house
characters all grown up we'll see you
next time
bye bye
[Music]